herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen wunsch ritz have
denn eine zuschauerin hat mir
geschrieben hat gefragt ob ich nicht mal
eine torte für einen jungen machen
könnte denn also ich muss auch ehrlich
zugeben main kanal ist schon ein
bisschen mädchen lastig liegt wohl daran
dass ich zwei töchter haben keinen sohn
habe und deswegen geht die tendenz eher
zum mädchen torten und findet auch ein
mädchen müssen oder zu sagen ja ja und
deswegen kam es öfter der wunsch und
jetzt mal ganz speziell noch mal der
wunsch nach einer torte für einen jungen
anlässlich des ersten geburtstags und
jetzt sonderlich gefragt mensch was
magst denn der kleine so aber das kam in
dem alter ja gar nicht sagen
und die zuschauer nicht glauben sie denn
sarah und sie hatte gesagt dass ihr sohn
gerne mit dem tod autos spielt und zwar
so typische begriff genau wenn man autos
die auch die sagen immer tut genau das
sind diese hier und diese gla spielt
aber auch ganz gerne mit denen das heißt
es nicht nur jungen spielzeug das ist
dass diese spielzeit nicht nur als
kleines kind gewünscht haben genau da
gibt es verschiedene fahrzeuge und die
heißen wirklich tut ich habe gedacht
dass sie das wahrscheinlich nicht so
bezeichnet heute hätten wirklich zum tod
flitzer und gibt ganz viele verschiedene
und zwar haben wir zum beispiel für die
ella sonne
eine flucht station am flughafen
und ich finde dieser war ganz toll die
machen auch geräusche aber nicht so
nervig gehäuse sondern
das macht so viel spaß
genau man hat immer dabei lernen müssen
ganz tolle lernen liter und man lernt
auch samira zum beispiel weiß nämlich
die feuerwehr feuerwehrauto dass sie die
112 wählen soll wenn's brennt und jetzt
rennt sie durch die wohnung
15 jahre
aber wie gesagt mir fiel auch damit ja
und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht komm
jetzt machen wir eine torte mit den tod
autos und entstanden ist diese torte ist
der einfache torte eben auch weil man
hat ja nicht immer so viel zeit und es
ist jetzt denke ich er mal was für
anfänger und was man eben einfach
nachmachen kann und im inneren der torte
haben wir noch eine regenbogen torte mit
zitronengeschmack als außen wie innen
sehr bunt und es kann jede mama auch
nachmachen aber genau denke ich auch ja
vielleicht sogar mit er nehme mit dem
einjährigen kindes
aber ich mit einem größeren kind ja weil
sie jetzt wissen wollte wie die torte
gemacht haben ich werde zuerst einmal
die teige herstellen und dann die creme
zu bereiten und später euch daneben
zeigen die dekorierte also ich sage
jetzt mal zutaten für die torte für den
kuchenteig und dann liegen auch gleich
für den teig brauche ich 250 g weiche
butter 250 gramm zucker eine prise salz
etwas weil extrakt sechs eier die sind
auch zimmer waren 500 milliliter zimmer
warme butter milch ein päckchen
backpulver und 500 gramm mehl
ich werde zuerst die butter nehmen und
sie gemeinsam mit dem zucker und dem
wandel extrakt unter prise salz richtig
cremig verrühren
jetzt kommen auch die eier nacheinander
dazu
jetzt wo ich backpulver und nähen und
dann kommen jetzt diese mischung und die
butter münchen immer nacheinander mit
den teig also in etwa drei portionen
der tag hat jetzt bei mir knapp 1800
gramm ich hab nämlich vorher die
schüssel abgebogen und so könnt ihr dann
immer abwägen wie schwer der teig ist
welche den sechs portionen einteilen und
damit die regenbogen torte schön
gleichmäßig wird und die schichten alle
gleich dick werden müssen die portionen
natürlich genau abgemessen sein sind es
bei mir etwa immer knapp 300 gramm die
ich jetzt hier auf die schälchen
verteile
jetzt nämlich lebensmittel fassen und
färbe den teig in gelb orange rot grün
hellblau und dunkelblau
und jetzt werden die teile einzeln in
vorbereiteten backformen gebacken und
zwar backe ich in zwei dramen mit
jeweils 22 cm durchmesser und die böden
müssen also sechs böden müssen einzigen
gebacken werden könnte einfach
nacheinander machen und der urteil kann
auch in der zeit wo ich ein bisschen
draussen stehen bleiben das macht gar
nichts
und die teile werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze für jeweils 20 minuten
gebacken und danach hatte komplett
abkühlen die torten bitten sind jetzt
alle abgekühlt und ich habs jetzt hier
schon mal hingelegt jetzt werde die
torte auch schon zusammen setzen und
zwar nehme ich jetzt dafür einen torten
retter legt den ersten boden da drauf
und kann das backpapier ab ganz unten
starte ich jetzt mit dem dunkelsten
boden das ist jetzt der dunkelblaue und
die habe ich jetzt einen toten retter
und hab da einfach ein stück backpapier
draufgelegt ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel buckley nehmen
jetzt lege ich das kurz zur seite und
wird schon mal die creme vorbereiten
und zwar habe ich für die creme bereits
ein grundrezept vorbereitet habe ich es
eine französische buttercreme und werden
daraus jetzt eine zitronencreme machen
und zwar nehme ich jetzt dafür etwas
lämmern gehört was ich schon vorbereitet
hat und es müsste jetzt einfach nach
geschmack abstimmen je nachdem wie
zitronen für das haben möchtet als
einfach ein bisschen lernen hört nehmen
jetzt gehe ich hier noch die buttercreme
mit das so und kann das levelcap
einrühren
jetzt wird die torte zusammengesetzt
wenn ihr möchtet und dem
zitronengeschmack erhöhen möchte oder
intensivieren möchte streicht hier
einfach noch etwas lernen gehört auf die
einzelnen teig böden und dazwischen
kommt dann die buttercreme schicht
jetzt kann ich den rand der tote so ein
bisschen glatt streichen und stellt die
torte dann gleich erstmal kühl und kann
sie dann danach mit der buttercreme
komplett einstreichen
welche ersten kühlung wird die torte
jetzt komplett mit der butter 10
eingestrichen und dann noch mal kühl
gestellt
alles einsteigen
modellieren hiervon stehen schon die tod
fahrzeuge und war nehme ich jetzt mal
den bus und habe jetzt hier blaue
modelliert schokolade modelliert
schokolade eignet sich hier auch jetzt
wirklich hervorragend zu modellieren
denn sie es nicht soweit londons und
hätte dann auch gut aus
ich nehme jetzt pro fahrzeug immer 100
gramm oder schokolade und die frau mich
zu einer kugel und dann vorm ich diese
typische tuut tuut fahrzeug form nach
also die autos sind die alle oben so ein
bisschen rundlicher und unten flach
ich werde sie tut autos modellieren und
zwar ich jetzt ein bisschen antrocknen
lassen und kann jetzt fondant und
modelle schokolade nehmen und auch
lebensmittel farbstifte um hier auf das
gesicht und die reifen und die lichter
und so weiter anzubringen
die einzelnen dicke teile werden immer
mit essbarem lebensmittels lebe
angeklebt
alles einsteigen los geht's
jetzt habe ich die autos soweit fast
fertig modelliert und jetzt brauche ich
noch ein kleines podest und zwar auch
aus modelle schokolade und es kommt dann
hier und hat damit die autos ein
bisschen erhöht sind
man sollte es aber nicht zu sehr sehen
dieses podest und dann kann ich gleich
noch die räder ausstechen und die auch
dran leben
mit buttercreme ein gestrichener glatte
torte wird jetzt mit von land überzogen
und dafür verknetet jetzt weisen und
land sondern und überziehe die torte
glaubt damit
modelle schokolade auf welcher strecke
aus und damit die modelle schokolade
gleichmäßig dick wie 42 holzstäbchen die
haben eine stärke von 3 mm und da wird
das jetzt alles schön gleichmäßig denn
ich brauche gleich sich straße und es in
der puzzleteile die zusammengeführt
werden und dass es immer gut wenn sie
daneben gleichmäßig hoch sind
damit die puzzleteile auch einheitlich
werden habe ich hier eine schablone
vorbereitet habe ich einfach aus einem
stück pappe ausgeschnitten und jetzt
kann ich hier schon mal die breite
einfach wegschneiden und die so
vorbereiten und las dann die modelle
schublade aber etwas an trocknen um ihr
vorne diese bilder auszuschneiden
dort sehe ich jetzt auch mit grünem
fondant und den strukturiere ich vorher
jetzt noch mit seinem struktur starb
die einzelnen puzzleteile müssen jetzt
an die torte geklebt werden und dafür
müssen sie jetzt einmal rund angepasst
werden
das heißt er legt sie dran und dann
könnt ihr immer mal wieder was kleines
wegschneiden um diese rundungen dann
einfach hin zu bekommen da ich diese
puzzleteile jetzt vom cache bord bis
hoch zur torte laufen lassen
mag
alle fragen
jetzt die torte zusammensetzen alle
dekret alle daran kleben
politisch fertig offen ich muss sagen
sind nicht mal so lange gedauert
ich habe heute morgen die böden
vorbereitet und die kühlen hier schnell
durch weiß ganz dünne bilden sind und
ansonsten nicht glaub ich hab jetzt
insgesamt noch mal fünf stunden
dekoriert aber mit ananas mit
zusammensetzen und es geht natürlich
auch alles viel schneller fallen wenn
man nicht mit firmen und ist es zu
probieren ist diese theorie muss ehrlich
sagen hast überhaupt kochen gekriegt als
kind also über bei uns war dass wir
gewinnen geburtstage feiern oder so was
war das will ich nichts groß ist und ich
habe wirklich ich kann mich nicht nur
die torte bekommt wahrscheinlich war die
torte zu deinem dreißigsten geburtstag
vor ein paar jahren die erste richtige
tor aber wirklich da ist es war bei uns
hätte ich ihn aber ich bis heute also
ich finde ihn und geburtstagen schön
holt aber fuß seien gern bei uns war das
nicht so bei uns war liebers gefeiert
ich esse ich traurig ich dadurch ein
schaden bekommen aber ich glaube da wäre
jedes kind glücklich darüber oder wobei
man dazu sagen muss also ich hab auch
für samira anzieht den ersten geburtstag
hatte eine geburtstagstorte gebacken
aber natürlich hat dieser mir nicht
mitgegessen also mit einem jahr fand ich
es schon bis hin zu viel mit kochen
ich glaube am zweiten geburtstag ab
damit gegessen war dann eher so die
geburtstagsfeier für die eltern erfahren
wie die mama finde ich immer sehr sehr
schön danke schön
bitteschön
richtig cool aus also es ist echt ein
augenschmaus
das freilich nichts essen was ich hab
gemerkt ja ich hab schon gemerkt er
schon sehr sehr saftig der kuchen mit
bisschen lemon kalt und einer
zitronencreme super dass durch die
beweist dass das motiv haben nicht nur
wird auf denkt diese prospekte
ich bin übrigens wie so ein joghurt ich
sage ja ok hat nur ein paar kalorien
mehr als im juni
also freut mich dass dir schmeckt und
falls euch dieses rezept gefällt dann
schaut gerne auf meinem blog vorbei aufs
eis - blog.de und ja ansonsten wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken und
ich lenke regenbogen dort kommt immer
gut an bord nun endlich sagen tut tut
also viel spaß beim backen von brot
schmeckt richtig bedrohlich
becker kam noch einmal
viel spaß
hallo liebe kinder heute
das taxi in reisebus und den
geländewagen zu einer spektakulären
stunts hallo ihr drei freut ihr euch
schon auf den großen sprung von der
action rampe in der arena finden die 77
stand spiele statt und alle drei sind
fans vom schwarzen rennwagen vor allem
dass es ganz aus dem häuschen tut baby
flitzer ihr seid einfach spitze